Here's my solution. First, I use randint to assign the true location of the car.
My initial guess, called guess1, is also chosen at random.
You see these independent random choices with equal probability.
Now there are two possibilities. Either truth is equivalent to guess or it isn't.
When truth is equivalent to guess, Monty will pick one of the two other doors.
Let's just implement this. I will let Monty pick a random door using randint.
Of course, he might have picked the correct door, which contains the car,
which is also my guess, and when that's the case I just rerun the random number generator
until it finally finds a door that is not the true door or equivalently not the guess.
That this pick. If we look carefully, this might run a number of times.
But when it returns, he picked one of the remaining doors at 50% chance.
In the else clause, the truth and my guess are not the same.
So, Monty now has to pick the remaining door with probability 1.
How do we get get Monty's choice?
Now I'm going to do a little cute trick.
I know that the sum of all doors--1 + 2 + 3--equals 6.
If I subtract from 6 the truth and my guess, I get the third door.
This equation--6 - truth - guess--will give us the number of the door that isn't truth
and isn't guess 1.
To flip my door, I can now do the same trick I did over here.
I pick the one that wasn't my initial guess, which is subtract guess1 from 6,
pick the one that isn't Monty. That gives me guess 2.
If that guess is the same as the 2 door, I increment k by 1.
Then I return the final number over here.
This gives me a single simulation.
I run through this n times.
So, I added a loop for i in range n, move everything to the right a little bit,
and then this simulation is run n times,
returning my desired ratio of the successes over the total number of experiments.
Let's run it.
When I run it 1000 times, I get a number like 0.672.
That's not exactly 2.3, but obviously there is some randomness involved in the simulation.
If I increase N to 10,000, I get a number slightly closer to 0.66.
Do it 400,000, I get 0.66748.
That is awfully close to 2/3.
It's really interesting to see that the switching helps.
Put differently, say I use guess1 as my final guess to compare to the truth
as opposed to guess2 and run this.
I get 0.331.
The interesting thing about guess1 is--the reason why it works is--
all the code from if truth all the way to here--guess2--is now irrelevant.
I can comment all of this out here in the middle, which I've just done,
and just retain the assignment of the truth, which is a random number,
the assignment of guess1, which is a random number,
and then I just check where these two agree.
Clearly, the probability must be a 1/3.
All this story about showing the open door has no effect on this.
That little thing here that I simulated and when I retained the original guess
then all the story about opening the door has no effect on the chances of my guess,
prove that the chance is to be 1/3 for the original door.
Therefore, switching goes up to 2/3.
Isn't that cool?
This is the story of Monty Hall and the very famous quiz.